if you've seen a ventures endgame now's
a good time to start unpacking exactly
how the MCU will cope with its losses
what those deaths mean for our heroes
and how future stories will be affected
if you haven't seen the film yet
consider this your first second and
final warning major spoilers ahead
marvel's infinity saga started with Tony
Stark so it's only fitting that it ends
with him
if Tony Stark had to die we're glad he
got to go out the way he did after
declaring I am Iron Man right in fan s's
face he snaps the mad Titan and his
whole army from existence of course
everyone is absolutely devastated in the
aftermath of Tony's death as we see at
the funeral for the armored Avenger
pretty much every surviving superhero
was in attendance and it's clear that
the loss will echo throughout the
community for years to come particularly
when it comes to those closest to him
like Peter Parker and Nick Fury and then
there's Tony's family happy Hogan is
clearly stepping in to be a kind of
father figure to Morgan stark promising
to buy her all the cheeseburgers she
wants but Pepper Potts his grief will
run deeper after years of worrying about
him she could see that Tony really was
at peace after ending his own personal
curse still she'll miss him every day
even if we never see this portrayed in
future films Black Widow was one of the
MC yous great survivors she faced down
countless super-powered threats and
personal demons throughout her life and
at least her death was on her own terms
this is gonna work Steve I know it is
because I don't know what I'm gonna do
if it doesn't natasha romanoff chose to
sacrifice herself so that her fellow
Avengers could get on with their lives
as she said all along she had read in
her ledger and this was the ultimate way
of wiping that out
sadly Natasha didn't get a funeral at
least not that we saw her death came
during the Avengers epic time heist and
we saw the grief in the faces of her
comrades as they swore to make her loss
worth it beyond the emotional loss
there's also a greater loss for the MCU
in the face of everything Natasha was
always the cool one under pressure she
became the field commander for the
Avengers in the years after the
decimation and the point of contact for
Heroes all over the galaxy now someone
else will need to fill her shoes and
it'll be hard to find someone who's up
to the task
Tony Stark is gone but the technology he
brought into the world is not his
inventions have heavily impacted the MCU
and to other superheroes proudly where
his tech there's war machine and now
there's Pepper Potts who suits up in her
own armor taking on an identity that
Marvel Comics calls rescue though it's
unlikely that Gwyneth Paltrow will
return to the MCU war machine will
probably still be knocking around
and Stark's Iron Man suits won't be
going anywhere in the public imagination
particularly after he saved the world in
such spectacular fashion with that in
mind it might be time to call upon a
young scientist to fill stark shoes and
take flight in his suits in the comics
there's a teenager named dreary Williams
who wear Stark style armor and calls
herself Iron Heart some fans have
speculated that Black Panthers little
sister Shuri could take on this
particular mantle in the MCU but perhaps
it'll be Starks daughter Morgan or a
character we haven't spent much time
with whatever the case the MCU is ripe
for new blood and iron heart could lead
the charge maybe with his last act of
heroism Tony Stark not only killed
Thanos but wiped away every last trace
of his minions and soldiers ridding the
universe of its greatest threat in the
first Avengers film the character known
only as the other gave Thanos a sharply
worded warning about fighting the heroes
of Earth
used to good sano simply smiled at the
words which is so Thanos and at the time
it seemed like a wink to the audience
members who knew that comic book fan
house had a massive crush on the bony
lady known as death and he literally
wanted to court her but now that endgame
has come and gone and the others warning
has been proven with the death of Thanos
that only heightens the cosmic
reputation of the earth and its heroes
there's a whole universe out there and
it all went through the decimation as
everyone recovers word will spread up
the heroes of Earth and how they were
the key to undoing all of Thanos work
that means future supervillains are even
more likely to fear earth it also means
there's a massive power vacuum that used
to be filled with Thanos and his minions
yes the universe's greatest threat is
gone but power vacuums have to be filled
on both sides of the good and evil
divide somewhere out there some madman
or mad woman is hell-bent on destruction
eager to get a taste of the Avengers and
prove they can beat them as vision said
this kind of power is bound to invite
confrontation as part of the entrance of
riri William says iron heart in the
Marvel Comics universe it was revealed
that Tony Stark sustains such serious
injuries in the Civil War - event that
he fell into a coma but he conveniently
made a copy of his consciousness
beforehand which was able to assist
dreary and freely chat with other Marvel
characters as a form of artificial
intelligence this Tony Stark AI became a
mainstay of the Marvel Universe and
retained all the wit and wisdom that
characterized Tony
Tony's last recording for his daughter
is just that a recording but considering
everything Tony has tinkered with over
the years including frequent artificial
intelligence ventures it's quite
possible that he would have taken a cue
from his comics counterpart and found
some way to record himself as a
consciousness hey miss Potts if you find
this recording
don't feel better at this this would
allow the character to carry on in some
form and it would create opportunities
for Robert Downey jr. to continue making
cameos in any upcoming MCU projects Tony
Stark the man would be gone but Tony
Stark the artificial intelligence could
live on if only as a voice and another
hero's head and an extremely sassy voice
at that we're going out of town okay
we've been through this nope yeah the
man says no great idea check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about adventures and
game are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]